hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the gauntlet of iron now
from what I've seen and what I've been
told and what I've read about this game
it's supposedly quite difficult now I
don't know how true that is and I don't
understand if it's going to be that bad
but I wanted to give it a chance to see
easy mode or hard mode I mean what's the
point of playing a rage game if you're
not gonna play in hard mode oh it's
locked
ok so I got to do easy mode first ok
alright
idiot proof huh ok alright well this
doesn't seem so bad it's a beautiful
game the guy admit okay alright little
why did you slow down what why'd you
slow down why would you have slow now
it's not obviously not idiot-proof if I
got to know no idiot no fool I like that
a sec [ __ ] but that's alright you know I
don't like the music going into this
because it suggests then I'm gonna go
crazy okay
wise know what why is that like that why
would that be like that okay
yes I know how to play I guess I don't
necessarily need to land on all of them
I can jump over something yeah oh so
dicey wait you're not like that now oh
very oh God I just got to jump over that
all right
easy peasy I know how to play the game
thank you very much I feel like I'm in
preschool like something about the
primary colors the fact that I'm rolling
the ball down a straightaway it all kind
of bring back to the idea that I'm just
an idiot child and I don't what am I
supposed to do how am I supposed to be
able to make that jump like am I
actually supposed to get through this
why am i communist ball that's the
things that I don't understand about
this can the music please change that's
all ask just a little bit variation
between everything that I got going on
whoa how are you supposed to get through
that how are you supposed to get through
that huh I mean I could show I don't
think I could jump over there yes
idiot-proof I'm aware I'm an idiot
and it's not idiot-proof I get it it's
it's different it is different it's
different every time but only slightly
enough to infuriate you ooh
making the jump go how uh how would you
do that
no no why why what why why did you do
that why did you do that why did you do
that why can I jump on my graves is that
something I can do can I dance on my own
grave
please that's something that I'm much
appreciate in this scenario
if I could just Oh make this yes why
because it's different it's different
wait no wait what are you talking about
it's different you changed it you
changed it
you made it random why would you make it
random that's the most infuriating thing
water what are you talking about let us
get dogged mean why would I get dog it's
different are you different why is it
different this is a big anis it's
usually it's something that you could
learn needs better at oh I got dog why
don't I just jump over that I can change
well okay I got your number now I got ya
I got ya I got ya got ya I got ya how
would you be able to do that anyway well
of course you do this stupid idiot
what do you think I am exactly what I
said you were shut up also you're ugly
and I'm handsome I'm gonna jump on that
I'm gonna drop on that okay we're good
oh I don't like the vigils are breaking
my brain I am not good or we go easy
peasy lemon squeeze me training wheels
come off okay impossible
says you that's him
[Music]
what what what what how how do you this
doesn't make any sense what do you what
are you talking about huh I just killed
a girl there Kelly okay all right you
know what I don't get that okay all
right all right staying positive I got
this I got this impossible my left nut
it's impossible I okay I have good
whoa whoa whoa easy there buddy boo get
some speed how about some speed huh this
is not blazing speed and a dong yeah
sorry okay it's fine I got the recipe
for fun times yes I am a happy sack of
[ __ ] it's gonna go around all of these
[ __ ] here I did it here I'm on the
high ground and I have a light touch it
is really cool and I like it oh I don't
like that I really don't like that
attack I'm not gonna make it okay here
we go
I got this it's a really cool game and I
have all Ruby white which I pet loss
[ __ ] kitties with my touch it it is cool
I am a good player of games here we go
I've forgot again oh [ __ ] me yo look on
me yo homie no I
not having fun it is really cool to be
in pain oh it's a light touch I forgot
about the light touch huh then why can't
I just be your new friend oh boy it's
not really cool oh boy light touch oh
that's not cool oh that's also not cool
I'm so fast I'm so fast why am I so fast
I made it gotta go fast I was like the
pillow I do no no I don't want to bite
the pillow no that doesn't sound very
fun to me I'm going real fast I don't
like this there was a little fast but I
am fine
baby come back to me I don't know what
do you want
oh gone real slow no no no no no no no
no no no where am I going wait what why
am i why am I going backwards what what
wait hey wait wait ha who is that
doesn't make any sense why would that
happen what why is this why is this
happening why is happening why why are
you doing this hey why doing this hey
hey come on we're doing no no no no no
[Music]
dog well I don't know where I am I don't
know what is gone
[Music]
how's that supposed to work you know
okay maybe I'm supposed to touch as
little as possible I don't know I don't
know this is supposed to be done
baby come back to me baby come back
please it's different now I'm different
now I've forgotten how to play oh come
on I'm over sick and so close oh please
yes yes yes yes I did it I am making
things worse now yes I don't want to do
that that sounds real bad reality is
shifting on me oh god oh god oh god oh
god oh yes I got a lot of things in my
why no please don't do that do me oh no
no no no I just let you go I don't
[Music]
finding that straight anymore why it is
a big it is no no how this is not I
don't dog me bro
what okay I guess I don't want to take
the scenic route no no I don't I don't
want to do it I just don't want to do it
[Music]
it's great
great just the way it is oh yeah god
damn it
hell [ __ ] me in the butt I am really
saucy in my hands and I will not be
denied I am the man I am the one that
will beat your ass into the grass and I
will win yes okay oh oh oh oh oh okay I
don't like no no no I was right there
god damn it god damn it okay I got this
my god this is for fun
goddamn that I hate I didn't have at
that time but I really had it I have
this the scenic route is full of
[ __ ] but that does not mean that I
won't be the guy who's good now I will
play this game until the day that I die
I just want to get through this one
level it's not that bad I don't think so
I won't be dead cuz I am the man who
will get the head I could explain myself
here we go again it's time to go on with
the show I don't know what to do with my
[Music]
boy this is gonna make me lose my sanity
ah it's such a simple game though
Pleasant one might say if they were
stupid why does it have to be random
don't do another developer chose this
this is a feature did you know this is a
feature guys oh no no I'm fine I'm fine
I am oh my god
I was fine I was fine I was fine I was
fine everything was going great in my
life I don't even have a wife it is just
strife in my life
oh boy now I can't wait to get that big
brown cow I hope I get a lot of greens
when I exchange it Gaurav Bienstock my
name is Steve oh god okay
yes almost gone that one ah yes yes yes
yes leap of faith no no no no no no no I
don't want to do that
[Music]
doop you do this level I don't really
know
now I don't understand what to do it's
not real fares out there alright I'm
done
no no no no nope nope nope nope nope I'm
going home so that was gone lit a fire
not impossible I didn't get that far but
oh my god oh my oh my god there's so
many levels nope nope nope not gonna do
it so I'm gonna leave that one there if
you guys want to see more than this let
me know down in the comments below I
think I'm up to the challenge so thank
you everybody so much for watching and
as always I will see you in the next
video
bye-bye
[Music]